[Musica]
utopia o realtà
obiettivo raggiungibile concreto
fattibile oppure follia in un mondo
sempre più determinato da logiche
consumistiche dello spreco dei materiali
dell'usa e getta
beh secondo me i rifiuti zero è
possibile non solo le possibilità ma
anzi è necessario e fondamentale per
costruire un futuro sostenibile
anzi per costruire un futuro possibile
perché non esiste un futuro possibile
senza sostenibilità
iniziamo questo breve viaggio da due
immagini da due grafici da due immagini
il primo grafico ci dice un dato molto
semplice preoccupante allo stesso tempo
il consumo di materie all'anno sul
pianeta terra
negli ultimi 100 anni e per i prossimi
se oggi siamo intorno a 85 giga
tonnellate l'anno entro i prossimi 30
anni
in questo trend arriveremo a 170 giga
tonnellate l'anno
peccato che gli scienziati ci dicono non
le avremo sul nostro pianeta e non ne
abbiamo un altro di scorta quindi
dobbiamo capire come poter conciliare
limiti fisici del nostro pianeta con un
diverso modello di sviluppo
l'altro grafico ci dice un'altra cosa
altrettanto importante è l'andamento
delle emissioni climalteranti la scintu
e atmosfera negli ultimi anni un
andamento crescente che ha determinato
cambiamenti climatici gli scienziati ci
dicono per circa un grado sul nostro
pianeta
quindi è un po come se avessimo la
febbre intorno a 37 l'accordo di parigi
stabilisce che dobbiamo stare entro i 2
gradi il massimo dei cambiamenti
climatici altrimenti per l'umanità sarà
molto molto pericolose difficile
continuare a vivere su questo pianeta
meglio tenerci entro il grado e mezzo
quindi questo è l'andamento che dobbiamo
dare alle nostre emissioni climalteranti
in atmosfera se vogliamo stare entro i 2
gradi
o meglio perché è meno rischioso entro
il creato e mezzo quindi se non vogliamo
arrivare a scenari che sarebbero davvero
preoccupanti e questo viaggio
continuiamo la in una bellissima città
italiana
chi di voi è mai stato a venezia città
meravigliosa
ecco peccato perché venezia come tutte
le città di mare saranno le prime
pagheranno le conseguenze più dure
devastanti dei cambiamenti climatici con
l'innalzamento dei mari che renderà
sempre più difficile vivere in queste
città
ma andiamo dall'altra parte del mondo
l'undici marzo 2017 una frana e la
discarica di addis abeba genere a 65
morti per lo più donne e bambini che li
intorno vivevano per raccogliere
materiali anche i nostri rifiuti e
continuare a dare vita a quel materiale
esprimendoci un po di quel valore che
ancora hanno ecco questa immagine non
può che suscitare c2 riflessioni
una è una scossa di responsabilità che
ognuno di noi sa per ogni scelta che fa
e l'altra è l'alternativa
le alternative che dobbiamo credere far
crescere più aumentiamo la
responsabilità di ognuno di noi più
facciamo crescere le alternative più le
alternative
crescono e prendono forza più possiamo
far crescere la responsabilità
collettiva e le alternative esistono e
proprio l'europa che ci sta spingendo
sta spingendo tutti i paesi europei
andare verso modelli di economia
circolare perché la nostra economia per
lo più è tradizionalmente lineare estrae
produci consuma carta è invece quello
scarto deve ritornare come materia prima
nella sostituzione delle situazioni
continue di materie prime
altrimenti non avremmo senz'altro nel
futuro né sostenibilità ma la strategia
rifiuti zero punta obiettivi ancora più
ambiziosi quali quelli appunto di
ridurre la produzione dei rifiuti sul
nostro pianeta
e se fino a qualche anno fa appunto
parlare di rifiuti zero sembrava
un'utopia
qualche mese fa ho avuto l'onore di
essere il primo relatore internazionale
del primo congresso mondiale di tutte le
città rifiuti zero
ci siamo trovati a brasilia la capitale
del brasile e c'erano città di tutto il
mondo dall'australia al giappone
all'asia
all'africa gli stati uniti è lì lì
abbiamo avuto la consapevolezza che sia
un movimento che sta crescendo nel mondo
e che sempre più costruisce e risultati
e vantaggi una delle più grandi città
del mondo che ho fatto questa scelta in
san francisco oltre un milione di
abitanti che ha avviato politiche di
riciclo per oltre l'ottanta per cento
dei propri scarti e con questo ha
evitato la costruzione di una nuova
discarica ha creato decine centinaia
migliaia di posti di lavoro attraverso
politiche di raccolta differenziata
riciclo riuso dei materiali fondamentali
e nel 2007
vedendo proprio l'esempio di san
francisco in italia abbiamo voluto
portare anche in italia perché nessuna
comunità aveva fatto ancora questa
questa scelta questa questo percorso e
siamo partiti da capannoni un comune di
circa 50.000 abitanti qua in provincia
di lucca a voler costruire questa nuova
sfida e tanti tantissimi ci dicevano che
era un'utopia che era impossibile
arrivare rifiuti zero ma abbiamo agito
su queste due leve la responsabilità e
le alternative
il percorso di coinvolgimento della
cittadinanza e in costruzione di
alternative alternative che alimentano
la responsabilità e quindi siamo partiti
dal primo passo fondamentale cioè quello
di eliminare sistemi di raccolta che
alimenta una irresponsabilità come
sistema di raccolta a cassonetto
sembrava di infrangere una religione a
togliere i cassonetti per strada
10 12 anni fa oggi per fortuna è una
politica che fanno sempre più tante
città in italia e nel mondo per invece
organizzare sistemi di raccolta
domiciliari che alimentano la
responsabilità perché così ognuno è
obbligato a prendere in mano i propri
scarti domandarsi e aumentare le proprie
responsabilità
e proprio attraverso queste politiche
che abbiamo costruito questo risultato
incredibile che sembrava impossibile
vedete in questo semplicissimo grafico
il rosso e tutto quello che prima una
decina di anni fa andava a smaltimento e
si sta assottigliando sempre più
tendenzialmente verso 0 grazie a due
fattori fondamentali
l'aumento delle raccolte differenziate e
la riduzione della produzione dei
rifiuti dove l'elemento centrale è stata
l'area
contabilità dei cittadini che abbiamo
alimentato tramite appunto questo
meccanismo semplice banale che la
necessità di doversi chiave ogni scarto
doveva e allora ci si inizia a chiedere
anche perché facciamo tanti scarti
iniziamo a vederli e quindi a capire il
problema ma abbiamo detto ecco
importante anche ridurre i rifiuti e le
prime cose che possiamo fare per chi ha
la possibilità e agire sull'organico
l'organico e circa il 40 per cento dei
rifiuti urbani è quello che crea
maggiori problemi quando finisce in
discarica che crea percolati crea
tantissime problemi ambientali e quindi
chi ha la possibilità di farselo il
compostaggio domestico e quindi di
trattarli in casa nell'orto nel giardino
è il primo passo da fare così non
facciamo viaggiare in camion quel
materiale
evitiamo alla terra quelle elementi
positivi importanti che gli abbiamo
tolto per fare coltivazione quindi è la
prima basilare cosa da fare per
costruire sostenibilità ambientale
ma chi abita in una città non ha la
possibilità di farlo quindi ci sono
sempre più impianti industriali che
permettono di trasformare le nostre
bucce di patata non solo in compost di
qualità che viene utilizzato in
agricoltura ma anche in sostituzione di
carburante in biometano come questo
impianto che a pinerolo in piemonte e
dove appunto si produce bio metano che
alimenta quei mezzi che fanno della
raccolta dei rifiuti in quella zona
quindi un modello perfetto di economia
circolare che sempre più si sta
replicando in tante in tante città
italiane ma dopo l'organico passiamo ai
materiali riciclabili secchi la carta la
plastica e metalli su ognuna di queste
filiere industriali potremmo fare
una relazione lunghissima scoprire
viaggi meravigliosi attraverso le
politiche del riciclo che generano
attraverso impianti molto più semplici
di quelli di smaltimento generano molta
più occupazione
si calcola che circa 4 5 volte di più
sia a rendimento economico e
occupazionale degli impianti di riciclo
rispetto agli impianti di smaltimento ma
abbiamo detto che rifiuti zero non punta
solo a fare questo primo passo e avviare
al riciclo tutti i materiali ma
l'ambizione di voler ridurre anche la
produzione dei rifiuti e non è vero che
ridurre la produzione rifiuti sia
sinonimo di privazione perché invece in
tantissime progettualità per ridurre i
rifiuti si è unito la riduzione dei
rifiuti allo sviluppo economico ad
esempio questo banalissimo è
semplicissimo progetto che in un'azienda
in piemonte ci ha visto creare due
marchi dell'eco ristorazione e dell'eco
albergo e li abbiamo conosciuti a quelle
attività della ristorazione e degli
alberghi che hanno adottato un
protocollo d'intesa accettando di
attuare 7 azioni su dieci possibili
almeno sette per ridurre gli impatti
ambientali e la produzione dei rifiuti
nelle loro attività commerciali questo
dato loro pubblicità quindi li ha fatti
conoscere e ne hanno beneficiato in
termini economici l'ambiente ne ha
beneficiato perché appunto si sono
prodotti meno rifiuti anche l'economia
locale ne ha beneficiato perché sia il
rialzo smaltimento meno rifiuti quindi
anche i cittadini hanno avuto un
beneficio quindi tutti ne hanno vinto
come questi sono decine centinaia le
progettualità che si possono attuare in
campo della riduzione dei rifiuti per
unire tutti i tipi vantaggi sociali
ambientali economici e occupazionali
l'altro passo fondamentale sempre per
ridurre i rifiuti e allungare il loro
ciclo di vita e agli studenti attraverso
i centri del riuso qualche anno fa ho
visitato questo spettacolare posto che è
il più grande centro europeo del riuso
l'ha costruita la città di goteborg
investendo 4 milioni di euro e in questo
spazio lavorano 30 persone
ogni giorno 200 cittadini vanno
acquistano qualsiasi cosa dalla porta
una finestra un sanitario
dell'elettrodomestico
e in questo modo dopo aver dato lavoro
ogni anno più di 30 persone versano al
comune gli utili di impresa
mediamente sono tra i 700 e gli 800 mila
euro l'anno di un investimento alquanto
letizia per il comune
ecco la stessa cosa l'abbiamo realizzata
al capannori proprio nella all'interno
della strategia rifiuti zero con un
centro che si chiama da capo che quindi
da vita è ritornata vita ai tutti i
materiali che vengono conferiti e dal
lavoro a 7 persone e questo appunto è un
modello che si sta sempre più replicando
in tante tante città in giro per
l'italia
ma passiamo a un passo ulteriore della
strategia rifiuti zero quello della
tariffazione puntuale
cosa significa significa applicare quel
concetto banale che da sempre siamo
abituati a pensare quando consumiamo
l'acqua e quindi la paghiamo in funzione
di quanta ne consumiamo oppure la luce
in funzione di quanta ne consumiamo
paghiamo perché non debba non deve
essere così anche per i rifiuti proprio
per alimentare quel senso di
responsabilità contro lo spreco che la
bolletta dell'acqua o della luce ci fa c
incentiva diciamo a fare e quindi è
partita questo concetto abbiamo fatto un
innovazione qualche anno fa appunto a
capannori inserendo per la prima volta
in italia un r fide un microscopico
microchip che ha applicato nel sacco o
anche nel bidoncino inserisce appunto i
dati dell'utenza che quindi è registrata
per ogni conferimento di materiale
indifferenziato che fa e questo appunto
permette di capire quante volte in ogni
anno il cittadino ha conferito e propri
scarti questo progetto è stato
candidato a un concorso che si chiama
innovation in politics e ringraziando
anche tutti i miei collaboratori abbiamo
vinto quel concorso come primo e unico
esperimento diciamo in italia di questa
progettualità
voglio far vedere il video che loro
hanno fatto proprio per riassumere il
nostro progetto waste una serire world
bank management puntuale gmg ranking
cast
[Musica]
ecco se con percorsi di raccolte
differenziate domiciliari
responsabilizzanti arriviamo a 70 all 80
per cento di avvio a riciclo di
materiali con la tariffazione puntuale
possiamo arrivare anche al 90 95 per
cento
lo abbiamo fatto a capannori ora lo sto
facendo in tante altre comunità seguendo
le in questo percorso di attuazione
semplice banale che ti mostrano cosa
semplicissima che non esistono
distanze che possano non permettere di
realizzare questi percorsi perché ci
sono percorsi simili al sud al centro e
al nord italia in piccole grandi e medie
città quindi basta la volontà di voler
raggiungere questi obiettivi ma non è
detto che quel 10 per cento quel 5 quel
15 per cento che sia che va ancora
smaltimento debba continuare a dare a
smaltimento all'infinito perché così
come il mercato delle materie prime è in
continua crescita di costo perché sono
sempre più scarse le materie prime lo
stesso le industrie anche le grandi
multinazionali stanno investendo sempre
di più per andare a prelevare il valore
dei nostri scarti non a caso vengono
definite le miniere urbane i nostri
scarti e non a caso proprio in italia
una grande multinazionale ha realizzato
in provincia di treviso questo impianto
questo impianto che per la prima volta
al mondo ricicla i pannolini pannolini
dei nostri bambini che dopo una fase di
sterilizzazione iniziale vengono
riciclati attraverso l'estrazione di
materie cellulosiche materie plastiche
che vanno nelle filiere della carta e
del recupero delle materie plastiche e
lo stesso succede a questo materiale
questo materiale si chiama pal per e
allo scarto del riciclo della carta sono
le copertine magari dei quaderni dei
nostri figli che finiscono per sbaglio
nella raccolta differenziata oppure sono
quelle etichette trasparenti nelle buste
che riceviamo a casa che quindi sono una
materia estranea nella raccolta
differenziata e finiscono alla
smaltimento ma se fino a pochi mesi fa
finivano solo a smaltimento
da qualche settimana grazie a
un'innovazione importantissima di
un'azienda del territorio
e un finanziamento importante a livello
europeo questo materiale va a riciclo e
quindi gran parte di questo materiale
viene intercettato e si avvista avviando
una filiera industriale per trasformarlo
in pallet che poi viene usato da altre
aziende per la logistica interna
allora se abbiamo visto che fino a
qualche anno fa ci dicevano che era
utopia era impossibile erano obiettivi
raggiungibili
oggi abbiamo visto che invece sono
sempre di più i vantaggi che si
costruiscono dalla fattibilità di questi
percorsi e ci stiamo togliendo anche
qualche soddisfazione perché ecco quando
riceviamo queste conferme queste
riconoscenze istituzionali questo è il
segretario europeo per l'ambiente bella
che appunto un paio d'anni fa in un
convegno in cui abbiamo illustrato le
migliori esperienze italiane nella
gestione dei rifiuti ha affermato che
proprio queste sono quei principi
ispiratori del pacchetto dell'economia
circolare su cui anche l'europa sta
lavorando per spingere tutti i paesi
europei verso la sostenibilità il
riciclo e la riduzione dei rifiuti
io voglio lasciare con l'immagine
stupenda che è la sacra di san michele
in in piemonte
cosa ci dice questa immagine che salendo
c'è una salita terrificante
faticosissima ma ci dice proprio questo
arrivare lassù che si vede un
meraviglioso paesaggio e tutte le volte
che ci si va se capisce che ne è valsa
la pena
ma si capisce anche un'altra cosa che da
quel bellissimo paesaggio si vedono
mette mete e obiettivi ancora piu alti
da dover raggiungere da poter
raggiungere e il bellissimo e la cosa
bellissima non è tanto raggiungerle
quanto il cammino che possiamo fare per
raggiungere e di quanto quanto capiamo
conosciamo scopriamo nel percorso che
facciamo per cercare di raggiungerlo
io ho dei figli e quando riguardo voglio
essere sicuro di aver fatto tutto il
possibile e l'impossibile per non
lasciare le loro un disastro come invece
purtroppo spesso vediamo e scopriamo che
stiamo facendo al nostro pianeta
auguro a tutti voi un buon lavoro grazie
[Applauso]